first of all the question I'm going to
ask is what actually fits in naturalism
and what doesn't and how do we decide
what doesn't fit in naturalism because
that's what that's what our alright
question this morning was about and Alex
made a strong claim that there's some
things that absolutely do fit and other
things that absolutely don't fit in
naturalism I'm not sure how to
adjudicate those things that don't I
don't know what they're like what their
features are that wouldn't fit in
naturalism and so my own view is is very
compatible in the bigger sense there's I
think that we've made a mistake by
getting rid of representational ISM in
in by in in psychology that we've get
gotten rid of too early a kind of
teleology in biology not that
evolutionary processes are teleological
but that organisms have in directedness
net in directedness matters and I'll
talk about that in a few minutes the
other worry I have here and this is a
term I get from Dan this idea of what I
was called greedy reductionism now I I
consider everything I do to be
reductionist and I'm very much I find
that there's should be no problem with
reductionism on the other hand I I
actually think that meanings are
causally efficacious in the world and
that they're that you can't do a good
job if you just have our current state
of very very reduced physics quarks and
gluons and their relationships or
whatever but in fact I think the way we
need to do is to begin to think about
the physics of dynamical processes
relationships and I think what we've
learned from complexities theories and
beginning with Philip Phil Anderson and
others that there is a lot of ways to
talk about physical processes in which
the dynamics the organization of things
matters and so part of the the game I
want to play today is to set things up
in which we stop thinking about
bottom-up and top-down causality I
actually think that there's a mistake in
in laying out the world this way I don't
think there's such a thing as top-down
causality but I am also antagonistic as
what I would call bottom-up causality
I think causality mostly is talked about
at whatever level whether it's the very
low level or the upper level in terms of
organization or you might say the
organization of dynamics that is their
structure and that structure determines
what happens and what doesn't happen
what's constrained what's not
constrained and in fact the term
constraint is very important for me
because I think it helps us get out of
that game of thinking that there's
ultimate stuff that does all the work I
think that the work is mostly done by
the constraints now one way to think
about it is that you know the laws I say
this is what can happen but what happens
in the real world is what can happen is
in a constrained context and those
constraints matter may determine what
does happen not just what could happen
and so part of what I want to get at is
that and what that basically says is
that means and this is my defense of
emergentism it's not like there's
something from the top down that's
controlling things or that it ever works
out that way but when new forms of
dynamical organization show up in the
world there are new causal consequences
that is that weren't there before and I
think the fact that we're sitting here
chatting at this table wouldn't have
happened you know 10 million years ago
because there are new causal
consequences in the world and that
happens it proposal might be just off a
stairs using the word level use scale
yeah yes yes I think that's that's what
it's a good answer there so so part of
what I want to do is to say look the
greedy reductionist move is to say no we
there is no upper upper level any
causality up at upper levels we're all
going to be able to reduce it down and
what I want to say is I think at the
very bottom level and one of the
problems with quantum physics is I see
it as an outsider is that it's in fact
it's all about a kind of dynamics even a
statistical dynamics the causality isn't
in stuff the causality is in the
organization and if it's in the
organization at the bottom it's got to
be in the organization all the way up
from those new kinds of organizations we
have to think about causality different
and that's not emergence in the classic
sense and I and I want to be clear I
think that we have to get out get away
from the top-down bottom-up
antagonism about emergence that I think
we want a completely reductionistic
understanding of the world but one that
doesn't throw out the levels these level
scales of dinah
Amyx that show up there novel and I
think they play a major causal No
you